swift whip reject nation we're gonna
watch today spider-man no way home toby
maguire and andrew garfield screen time
revealed this has come from the youtube
channel marble minute news uh this
channel was recommended to me from a
buddy warren over at cosmic wonder this
is one of his best friends ally i've had
the notification bells turned on for
this channel i've listened to quite a
few of ali's videos so far and this
popped up and i was like ooh uh you know
what why don't we react to it it's a
small channel right now and i figured
know will you give a little bit of a
little bit of a plug to this channel
since i've been listening and getting
some news from her it's not a paid
promotion
even though it sounds like a half-assed
attempt at
doing a paid promotion
no one asked me to do this i hope ali is
okay with it she'll be good as long as
we all get our checks from marvel i
think she'll be fine no the check for
marvel joke
hey i'll find a new joke
um as soon as uh the dc zack snyder
stops paying me to i don't know what are
you tyrone magnus that's right
[Music]
hey everybody welcome back to marvel
minute news i'm allie and today we're
going to be talking about more
spider-man no way home spoilers today we
have some information about toby mcguire
and andrew garfield when they're going
to show up in the film and what they're
going to be doing now we have a few
pieces of information obviously there's
a lot more going on in the entire film
but this is a snippet of what to expect
and as i mentioned spoilers ahead so if
you don't want any spoilers don't watch
the rest of the video way past that
point that we've been given is that toby
mcguire and andrew garfield will have a
total time of about 30 minutes on
that that's good that's good it's over
two hours that was revealed quite
recently so it's confirmed that they're
going to be playing a bigger role than
just a guest star cameo role because
they're actually going to be in 30
minutes or so of the film
yeah i mean that's perfect because the
film i believe the current estimated
final run time because before it was a
little over two and a half hours now
when i go on social media everyone's
saying it's exactly two hours and 28
minutes and if 30 minutes of that run
time can be of andrew garfield and toby
maguire you can imagine this movie would
have a good enough amount of time to
build up getting them in there and it
wouldn't just be some glorified cameo at
that point it actually seems like it'd
be perfect supporting characters for a
film that would ultimately still feel
like tom holland's movie yeah yeah
they're accounting for like one-fifth of
the overall run time which is you know
pretty substantial and like 30 minutes
of screen time you might hear that out
of a two and a half hour movie and be
like oh man that's not much but that
time goes a long way yeah 30 minutes of
time is a lot of time and use it for the
right qualitative purposes that could be
absolutely excellent because you got to
give screen time to all the villains who
are showing up too and you got to make
sure this is tom holland's story at the
same time as well and it's got to be a
build up you know what i just real i
thought of what if
what if you know how in civil war late
into the movies when they introduce
peter parker and it cuts to the shot
queens that's that what if they did
something like that
but like when they did toby mcguire
instead of whatever earth they're from
yeah
oh two no two zero zero two obviously do
queens and then all of a sudden fades in
yeah earth whatever else you know andrew
garfield earth tobey maguire earth oh
that would be so cool i would lose my
mind wouldn't that be cool kitties yeah
yeah kitties whoo that's hot of copper
everyone in this house loves spices
let's continue this during the film
they're going to be helping peter solve
the multiverse problem when they first
both show up and that's not going to be
at the beginning of the film it's a
decent way in however when they do show
up they're going to be helping peter as
scientists first more oh yeah okay
they're going to be figuring out what's
going on and how they can fix the
multiverse that's where we're going to
have the crossover of all the characters
and then they're gonna suit up in their
spider-man suits and they're gonna help
peter tom holland fight the final five
during the final battle of the film i
actually like the sound of that quite a
bit that's the first time i've heard
them allude to science that way but yes
exciting piece of information is like oh
they're all gonna put their heads
together before fighting everybody
because you're really gonna get to see
them use the peter parker skills because
immediately the first thing you think
about is them just you know doing like
oh there's three spider-man on camera
but at the same time a lot of that's
probably gonna be when it is three
spider-man it's gonna be mainly cgi it's
gonna be cool to see them web slinging
around and stuff don't get me wrong it's
gonna flip a [ __ ] when that actually
does go down but in terms of like when
they actually do meet up and then
talking about science putting their
heads together that is super peter
parker-esque ed to be getting that side
of all them and a lot of tom holland's
character his version of peter parker
actually let that shine through for the
first time and what feels like forever
that was gonna be awesome that's gonna
be excellent yeah bring it let's do it
let's do it that sounds great comment
down below if you have any ideas of what
else you could think is going to happen
between the three spider-man don't
forget to hit that like button and
subscribe for more updates on marvel
minute news
you got it ally thank you you got it
what'd you think about ally have you
seen any of these videos yet i this is
my first full one full one yeah like a
minute i have a low attention span man
and i'm like give me that news let me
skip through the juicy [ __ ]
get there fast now i've seen her channel
around but this is the first time i've
actually watched a video and what do you
think i quite enjoy i mean you know you
present everything very clearly you
clearly got the passion for this stuff i
i liked it a lot she seems like your
kind of girl that's right
mathematically speaking you are exactly
the right person for me and we should
meet up you know what i'm getting at i
mean she looks like the kind of girl
you'd be pretty attracted to
it's possible yeah i mean what do you
think she's quite attractive oh my god
john that is no cosmic
chris
that is his wife you perverse oh wow oh
no i did was not baiting i mean she i
can't believe you should say that i have
no such attractions to anything
i'm asexual now you sick bastard i will
never ever admit to attraction ever
again this is why i'm so cagey about
these cosmic because i'm always afraid
of this exact scenario chris said it
might be coming to california and we're
supposed to meet him now i can he might
bring his wife and now now she's not
going to feel comfortable being arrivals
now because you were being a disgusting
man about the love i think i was being a
pig in a chauvinist
i'm sorry ally ally disrespect listen up
but you're doing a great job here and i
love this spider-man you're better at
making more videos than me
you're doing an excellent job and uh we
have that chair don't we we do you're on
the seats everybody
get good taste and share that's what i
like the most about ellie is her taste
in chairs yeah is that what you were
looking at you haven't yet i was looking
at the and to see because i love money
and advertising and brand name
recognition sorry for john's ways he
will soon be getting cancelled don't
worry about it
guys handled he's back on and also uh
subscribed to marvel minute news some of
this i've heard rumblings about like a
few months ago that like toby mcguire
and andrew garfield's run time might be
around like the 20 to 30 minute mark
yeah i'm sure a lot of these reports
come from like big screen leaks daniel
rpk actually i did find out this was
reported by daniel rpk first he's pretty
reliable source that man you know you
know a lot of the same usual scoopers
but this is like quick quick minute news
and so a lot of times it is like
really useful just to give it a quick
listen yeah good digest yeah yeah for
sure all right guys thank you so much
for being here what do you think about
them being in there for only 30 minutes
if that is the case leave your thoughts
down below
you